okay yesterday I told you that Donald
Trump sought a Moscow real-estate deal
while running for president it involved
his attorney Michael Cohen it involved
this Russian American business guy named
Felix Seder we've now learned even more
about the blatant nature of the
coordination that took place as well as
about the relationship of these possible
real estate deals to Donald Trump's
political campaign and it all now is
involving Vladimir Putin and it's kind
of looking exactly like what we
suspected for a long time so Felix Seder
is the Russian American business
associate of Donald Trump back in 2015
he was trying to put together a real
estate deal specifically with Vladimir
Putin's help which he believed would
help Donald Trump win the presidency of
the United States
how are all aspects of this connected
well we've now learned that Felix aider
who again he's been on our radar for
some time we've talked about Felix Sater
before and I gave you some details about
him yesterday he wrote a bunch of emails
to Donald Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
who is a pretty important figure in the
Trump Russia blackmail dossier and in
those emails
Felix aider was bragging about his ties
to Vladimir Putin and he predicted that
if they could get this Trump Russia
Moscow trumped our deal done that it
would make Trump look like a really
great negotiator and it would help him
in a presidential race we now have our
hands on some of these emails here is an
email from Felix aider sent to trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen
in 2015 where he said our boy can become
President of the USA and we can engineer
it I will get all of Putin's team to buy
in on this I will manage this process
this is as blatant as it can get this
wasn't like a vague or mere general
statement sader claimed to have already
set up the financing for this Moscow
Trump Tower specifically with the VTB
Bank that's also relevant
since VTB Bank is under American
sanctions for Russia's influence in
undermining Ukrainian democracy another
story that we've been talking about for
a while now of course there are many
caveats here right Seder claiming to be
close to Vladimir Putin is not proof
that he's actually close to Vladimir
Putin right he could have been
exaggerating for example every
indication is that regardless of what
Felix seder promised Michael Cohen very
little of this actually happened and of
course as I told you yesterday the
Moscow Trump Tower deal eventually fell
apart they ended up not getting the
permits that they needed they ended up
not having the financing for the project
but here's where you sort of have to
read between the lines and really look
at what isn't being said when the White
House was asked for comment they
declined they initially didn't respond
to the Washington Post report that I
told you about yesterday now the New
York Times has built on that report and
they were able to get a comment from the
White House and the statement from the
White House and again you've got to look
at the language that they use the White
House responded to the New York Times
report by saying quote to be clear the
Trump Organization has never had any
real estate holdings or interests in
Russia okay that's a statement that we
got yesterday what they mean is no deal
happened
nothing was built it doesn't actually
deny or refute any of what we've learned
from The Washington Post and The New
York Times about Felix aider and Michael
Cohen because it all appears to be true
we've got the email records Pat and when
you look at the wording here they didn't
do the Trump Tower deal that's their
defense which doesn't refute any of the
reporting I think this also goes to this
idea that if there is collusion it's
more financial collusion than about
politics because I don't know if Trump
expected to win the presidency back in
2015 maybe at that point it was just a
big commercial for him still yeah and
Felix Sater is on this idea that just
getting this deal passed would make him
look like such a great negotiator that
Americans would have to elect them but
that's not really a voting issue is it I
don't believe it is I think that it
reflects more Felix aiders desire just
Monni right I think that that's what
what is underlying this and more and
more this entire Russia thing is
pointing more towards financial misdeeds
greed cronyism and the like listen folks
this I can tell you the fake news media
New York Times is failing by the way is
making this all up and by the way Russia
no I've had no contact with Russia Putin
never met him this is all to cover up
that crooked Hillary got schlonged by
the DNC Americans don't care about this
David Clarke's new book tremendous by
the way reading Baron does incredible
things with books he knows hundreds of
words and why would it be bad to be
friends with Russia anyway shouldn't we
want Pat better relations with Russia oh
man
and I think Felix Seder as well is one
of these Trump associates who has a
tough time keeping his mouth shut
yeah because he said that he was going
to show Putin and other Russian
officials video clips of Trump boasting
about how he loves Russia so much yeah
and that Seder wanted to become the
ambassador to the Bahamas if Trump was
to win well seder is a growing figure in
all this as a sort of a side because pat
opened the door to exploring Saders
history sure I will mention Seder
supposedly not that long ago said that
he expects both he and President Trump
are going to end up spending time in
prison in about the next 30 to 35 days
he said in an interview with New York
Magazine earlier this month he believes
he will be the quote most colorful
character you have ever talked about the
calls are coming from inside the house
I'm sort of starting to think guys that
there might actually be something really
to the Trump Russia investigation yeah
I'm starting to go in that direction and
for those who still say there's nothing
here the story has been unraveling for
more than a year and nothing's been
proven wrong there are aspects that
remain unproven right like this Donald
Trump really have a fetish for urinating
on Russian prostitutes it has not yet
been proven it's in the Russian
blackmail file but the longer it goes
the more of the Russian blackmail file
that that is verified or corroborated or
appears to be true if this entire Trump
Russia thing were submitted as a
screenplay like to a movie studio if you
gave this to Steven Spielberg he would
through it and he'd say nah it's too
contrived and the dialogues aren't
believable nobody would ever really
write emails like these and I don't
believe that at someone like this could
ever become President of the United
States it just doesn't seem believable
as a fiction script and it's real life
2017 this is gonna be an interesting
week I would predict maybe it's more of
a TV series where you can see that the
episodes keep getting renewed and
there's more and more seasons but it's a
conclude at some point the storyline of
what's happening is when a show does
well in seasons 1 & 2 and they never
really expected to get to season 3 but
they get renewed and now the writing
starts getting a little bit far-flung
and difficult to believe and you're
saying you know it's just no longer
believable that's reality right now it's
like Game of Thrones - or there's so
much turnover in the characters I mean
remember Anthony scaramouche II he was
around for like a week yeah although
I've never seen an episode of Game of
Thrones so I can't oh yeah Pat
signalling to go to a break that's not
something that I should be talking about
ever never mentioned I haven't seen Game
of Thrones I'm on Twitter at the Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show follow me there
today's episode is made possible in part
by Blue Sky a binary there are millions
of forex traders around the world and
80% of them lose money and I actually
have been dabbling in forex trading
since I was like 16 years old and I've
lost some money doing it and usually
when people lose money in this it is
because they either lack the appropriate
knowledge they might be relying on
others auto traders or other traders
they follow instead of themselves
sometimes people get emotional or take
bigger risks than they should or not
understand or follow proper money
management rules and blue sky binaries
education course sort of helps to
mitigate every single one of those risk
factors they're a leading financial
education and tech company focused on
forex they've got senior trading traders
with real trading experience offering a
structured and self-paced course that
you can take video on-demand online
tests one on one education sessions and
access to their community of traders are
all part of that course david pakman
show viewers and listeners can register
right now to get a free one-week trial
at blue
guy binary.com slash david that includes
access to their training platform and a
session with a senior trader to go over
the basics if you want to continue after
that it's $99.99 a month you can stop or
resume at any time once again that's
blue sky binary.com /d AV ID